e
e e
okay uh it is 10:30 my bad it's actually
10:32 so my apologies uh we'll start off
with
um representative Ward why don't you
lead us in the pledge today
okay um going to open up the uh this
meeting of the we're in election law
right now represent L uh the committee
house committee on Election law um just
so everybody knows we're not we are
going to have exec this right after this
but we're not taking a vote uh um so
it's been noticed but it'll be noticed
again for next Tuesday um because I
thought this was going to be last
meeting and then another bill came
through and I was like well I don't have
to do the same day vote uh same day
hearing and vote if we're going to be
meeting anyway so we're meeting again
next week for the per the exec for today
will be next Tuesday uh and we will next
Tuesday's bill of
537 uh we will do same day hearing same
day exec because that will be our last
meeting yay
confetti um okay so now we are on to uh
Senate Bill uh 534 relative to campaign
Finance thank you senator gray for
joining us for the purpose of here
introducing the bill um Senator gray
welcome uh thank you my name is James
Gray I represent Senate District 6 which
starts up in Halton and gilmington and
comes down Route 11 to
Rochester um certainly campaign finance
that you see in
534 uh as a basis for this bill we took
some of the work that you guys have done
uh in this committee
um but since uh the Senators seem to uh
get involved much much more in campaign
Finance than many of the house members
uh there were things that we thought uh
would be better served if uh it had our
input and so that's what you've got in
front of you uh certainly uh yesterday
at 11:30 uh there was going to be a
meeting uh between uh representative
Lane uh representative bar myself and
the minority leader in the Senate um to
go over the things especially the things
that representative Lane put together um
talking about the bills and uh uh that
didn't happen because of uh a particular
bill that seemed everybody wanted to
talk about uh so right now uh my
assistant uh my Aid is trying to
reschedule that I believe that she has
sent uh invitations out to you two uh
she's gotten a response from uh uh
Senator Susi uh and I think that uh
we'll be able to uh uh resolve those
and at least come to to some kind of an
agreement to to move forward the bill uh
and it uh uh looking at your schedule I
don't know that that's going to happen
uh along your timeline in enough time to
uh uh make it so that the next meeting
is your last meeting but we'll give it
that good old uh legislative
try uh so if you have any questions
certainly I'd be willing to answer them
uh but uh campaign Finance reform is
needed um certainly you know reports
that people can file right now that uh
people can't read don't do anybody any
good um and uh other changes that we put
in there combining groups together so
you don't have a candidate or a
candidate committee and they combine
those together and a few of the other
things that are done in these bills uh
certainly will have uh advantages to
people okay will you be taking questions
Senator whatever okay are there uh
questions from the committee on Senate
Bill
534 oh yes uh representative l
okay thank you um Senator gray I know
we're going to have that meeting but my
my question is one of the differences is
that we have a mandatory F you know
online file filing for the after 2004
and I don't think that's in the Senate
bill was that one of the concerns that
the Senators
had um when I look at campaign filing um
it is uh interesting that uh uh more
people of one party file electronically
than the people of the other party and
I'll let you figure out who that is um I
have no objection to
filing um electronically except that uh
you know some of the people will find it
much more difficult uh at least the
first time they
file um to do it that way um it does
provide a level of
readability uh and the question as to
whether or not you can attach documents
to it um the uh my last opponent in the
senate race
um she was very
um concerned that I would tell her that
you know that she could do different
things differently uh one of the things
that in her first filing is that uh she
provided her campaign $5,000 and her
husband provided her campaign
$55,000 and listed it as a contribution
and I says well you know if you really
wanted to do that if you listed it as a
loan and you received more funds
afterward than you know you could uh uh
recoup some of that money um and she was
kind of you know taken back fact that
her opponent would actually help her in
trying to do this uh but I don't know
how many of you have uh you know listed
your your contributions and had the AG
come back and saying hey uh raise your
hand I'm going to slap it because you
didn't put your uh donors in
alphabetical order okay um you know
people don't understand that you know in
the the receipt section you can have
loans you can have different things in
different categories Ries um which you
know makes it much
more um financially
uh sensitive okay to to to what you need
to do um and the online system helps you
through that and some of the new
features that they've got uh so I you
know I went to them and I says okay now
you know the interest rates are up now I
have to worry about uh the the funds
that I have in my campaign account
accruing interest and you know how do I
put that in there and it
says you know and again you know some of
those things are taken care of in the
new system so I look forward to to using
the new system I haven't logged in I've
told that some people have had great
difficulty in doing that um but uh the
next report isn't due until June so I
think I've got some time
further questions from the
Committee hearing none thank you Senator
gray um only other pink card I have is
uh deputy secretary of state Aaron
Hennessy is the the only other person in
the room because we have no
friends good morning aarin Hennessy
deputy secretary estate good to see all
of you um we are in support of this bill
we are also in support of the houses
version ideally what we would like to
see is just kind of a combination of the
great things that both of them have in
them to um Senator Gray's talking and
representative Lane's question um the
requirement that it be filed through the
new campaign Finance system I think is a
good thing and one of the reasons why
other than for transparency purposes is
that um when we take a document and scan
it up and put it online it is not ad
compliant um and it's not accessible on
our website and um the US doj has come
out with um the eternal general has come
out with uh a new ruling and the
requirement um by a certain amount of
time that everything like that document
needs to be accessible so um we our
office would if somebody doesn't file it
online would have to manually type in
everything so that it would be
accessible um which we just don't have
the staff to do um so that is is one
thing we like about um The house's
version we also like some some of the
definitions um that are in The house's
version um we like the some of the
things that are in the Senate's version
the the political
action Pao um uh advocacy organizations
the definition maintaining that
definition in there makes it clear that
they still have to register and file
with our office
um trying to think several other things
but I'm happy to I'm right now I'm going
through and kind of combining the two um
together um another thing might be the
definition of of the size that needs to
be have the um disclaimer on it the
Senate kept the I think it's 72 square
inches which is the size of a um bumper
sticker in there our office does get a
lot of calls about the the language
currently in statute of what what's a
button what do I need to put a
disclaimer on if I do give out little
magnets do I have to put the disclaimer
on that and um buttons can be various
sizes it right now it includes cars does
wrapping a campaign bus not mean to be
disclosed or a big box car that goes
down the street so we would like to see
that a size be put in there just so
users like yourselves um don't have to
make a judgment call and have somebody
call the AG's office on yourselves I'm
having to answer question questions I'm
also happy to share with you our
combined document once I get it
completed questions on the committee I
can you send that letter from the AG's I
wasn't aware of that AG's Ada letter can
you send that over to us it's the it's
United States oh it's us AG yes but I'm
happy to share with you the their final
ruling hasn't been put up on
their yeah this a certain website once
it hits that website then there are um
you get two two to three years depending
on the size of your local or state
government to comply with it so um yes
I'm happy to share that with the yeah
that' be that' be good because that will
probably change some things um any other
questions from the committee mine wasn't
really a question more uh all right uh
seeing none thank you um any other
members of the public wish to speak no
um there's no one on the blue sheet or
at least not that I saw when I checked
in a minute ago uh online there was one
per two people signed up One support one
opposed
uh for this hotly contested bill so with
that we will close the public hearing
for
um uh Senate Bill
534 and I guess I get to sit here until
11: so I can open and close our exac um
so any wants to come and hang out uh
we're closing the public hearing if any
wants to hang out for the uh shortest
executive session on demand you're more
than welcome too all right see you guys
next
week
e
e e
okay it's 11:00 a.m. so I'm going to
open up the public notice executive
session going to open up the executive
session on uh Senate Bill uh 534
relative to campaign finance and I'll be
recessing these uh vote on Senate Bill
uh 534 uh and we will see you next week
this concludes our executive
session
e e